senators house say you
is the respondent donald john trump
guilty or not guilty
mr burr guilty donald trump
impeached for inciting an insurrection
respondent donald john trump former
president united states
is not guilty as charged in the article
of impeachment
now acquitted at the site of the siege
the senate the trial revived the human
horror
of a protest that became a riot
you fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore
but senators decided donald trump was
not to blame
democrats framed it as a legacy defining
moment
this is almost certainly how you will be
remembered
by history that might not be fair
it really might not be fair but none of
us can escape the demands of history
and destiny right now they argued mr
trump
whipped up the mop with lasting
consequence
the officers who struggled to recover
from the injuries they sustained
to protect us
they struggled to recover today but the
defense team argued mr trump's words
were just
ordinary rhetoric the trial
unconstitutional
congress has no authority no right and
no business holding
a trial of citizen trump let alone a
trial to deprive him
of some fundamental civil rights in a
lengthy statement his client delivered a
familiar lament and
declaration of victory this has been yet
another phase of the greatest witch hunt
in the history of our country mr trump
said
no president has ever gone through
anything like it
in the months ahead i have much to share
with you and i look forward to
continuing our incredible journey
together
to achieve american greatness for all of
our people
but was this more of an escape than an
acquittal
listen to the incredible unease of the
most senior republican
there's no question none
that president trump is practically
and morally responsible
for provoking the events of the day
therein lies the tension a president
given a lifeline
by those who no longer support him a
problematic road ahead
for all involved